siamo due ex non sapevi finire la porta
con un pacchettino quindi lo vuoi un
caffettino erano quanto è un cassettino
io mi accorgevo tirato e minato che
aveva ucciso tre nel momento in cui mi
devo fare il classico rumore
cassetti 6 31 st ristretto ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di vita
buttata all'interno della puntata di
oggi è esperienze sessuali orribili
questo tema mi terrorizza
particolarmente motivo per quello sto
facendo e perché è stato veramente
richiesto tantissimo e quindi mi sono
detto vabbè o la va o la spacca troviamo
un modo per cercare di mantenere questa
cosa comunque dignitosa ed è così che ho
pensato comunque di evitare all'interno
degli studios di casa mia una persona
anche qui ed emotivi che non posso dirvi
perché non voglio che questo canale
venga chiuso sto parlando niente popò di
meno che della mia cresce amica
valentina ciao
lo sai che l'inizio che un altro modo
per presentarsi si sono avute governa
che tu mi avessi da pino tutto e merlo
però non hai chiamato questa rubrica
esperienze sessuali penose quest'anno
tutto ragazzi se vogliamo la pace
dove sta il computer nel quale sentiamo
il mio portafogli computer nature caduto
ma non abbiamo priore allora mi ha detto
una cosa vale mi raccomando facciamo
attenzione perché cernia mamma salva che
ci guarda te lo da mamma ciao marghe
quindi quello che ho pensato per rendere
tutto questo decente invito è stato
vuole chiedere su facebook e instagram
di non darmi dei messaggi vocali che non
fossero troppo espliciti ma che in
qualche modo in donassero la pillola con
delle allegorie un pochino come tante
quella divina commedia senza notate che
scusami
ovviamente io che sono foto che ha messo
tua madre vogliono tornare
no no no parliamo parliamo le perché mi
vede mia mamma poi comunque adesso le
foto perché gli screenshot nella
bellissima scena il romanzo la ballata
nel torino
e come non ho chiesto ma perché mamma
responso beh io voglio il nipotino a
breve insomma non sei più carne giovane
partire gli stupidi far vedere che a
trent'anni si può comunque rimanere con
un quoziente intellettivo inferiore alla
media siano 19 perdiamoci mai un piccolo
monaldi che stai a di
ci è sembrato non sono sempre esistiti
salmi riprende di guarirlo ma continuo a
voler volare a stare male
io immagino questo uccello monocolo e ti
guardava
[Musica]
chino di parma tinchi il bisogno di cui
ti voglio parlare è successo qualche
mese fa ero con la mia ragazza e come di
solito preferisco fare sono diciamo che
è entrato in casa con cappello
evidentemente sono un tipo freddo
il problema è stato e ne sono uscito
senza allora dopo qualche attimo di
panico per ovvi motivi è il dopo qualche
ricerca nata in fumo o ti sto a lei di
cercare in casa sua magari lo conoscerà
sicuramente il tutto ho avuto esito
negativo dopo attimi di ulteriore panico
ho detto vabbè su punto cerco io in casa
sua
fortunatamente dopo la ricerca non
troppo forzata non troppo esplorativa
tra virgolette
ho trovato il mio benedetto cappello un
po stropicciato ma ho trovato mai
esplorate a casa sua cioè comunque piani
i nostri piani
comunque c'è quanti metri quadri di casa
però ricordatevi sempre che comincia il
mio nonno la casa nasconde ma non ruba
riceveva questa è un cappello comunque
ragazzi ok che la casa è grande ma è un
cappello
beh dopo ti nascondo un cappello in
occasione di a mosca per i ragazzi in
discoteca ci prova con queste gare siamo
le poche che ci stuzzichiamo e dice
l'orecchio che
la regina dei tuffi chiamiamo le
carriere dei segni lo vedevi l'opera
fino all'altezza delle norme indica
pieno pensiamo se tu mi ha cercato nino
strano sugli alberi stanno comunque è
meglio ai funghi funghi questo tuffo
tempo con minuto nei vari cantasse
gargamella reati scusateci per l'audio
abbiamo avuto un piccolo problema si è
scaricata la videocamera sono andato a
mettere in carica la batteria e non so
in che modo si è staccata la spina
quindi il computer è impazzito
fino ad adesso avete sentito un audio
così come si diceva no
riprendiamo adesso con diciamo un po di
audio cantina che piacere averti qui
comunicato
tu e le tue male di brioni ha fatto
cilecca il computer
[Musica]
fortunatamente quando una basta visitare
che di testa ea certe che viene detto sì
dato in mano basta diventa stata trovata
accanto a uno stop la mente reattiva che
brutto lavoro l'elettricista il cibo
veridiana di man
la scossa è tornato a casa un po
bruciato si no lei continua ve l'avevamo
capito se tu dici smettila di avere
l'adattatore meno insomma ed invece
parlando di spine poi traparente
maledetto esprime di raggiungo ciao ho
visto il tema è questa settimana di vita
bucata e ho detto no a questo ragazzo ha
deciso di portarmi devo stare un po
tranquilli nei fatti di non sul taro
veste l'abito io non c'era anima viva la
performance nata malissimo perché il suo
gigi non collaborava per niente nel
senso che non raggiungeva livelli di
altezza su frizzi e quindi di servire
qualcosa e poi
perché secondo me il problema era delle
mie amichette le cose dicotomia fare
certe cose ma a casa mia che devo fare
all'amore con qualcuno deve essere un po
di mammola sintomi sono grato e kharja
un bacione cyber shot ragazzo bellissimo
e bellissimi diritti gay come ha cercato
di fare quello che definisco l'effetto
piegare la manica della cioè fa mica
pena ok col dito e tu capitolo set in
poi senti di rimboccare si è l'effetto
delle sarte ma tu hai avuto esperienze 6
parlando io sono così casta e pura e la
mia madre che guarda che non tu una
tunica allora c'è questa mia amica che
li sceglie proprio sempre con l'unar
milano scuri camicia
ok la peggiore che lei ha vissuto questa
tua amica allora questa mia amica si
frequentava con un ragazzo un po più
giovane ho tanto più giovane si parla
sempre comunque un po di dimensioni ma a
parte la dimensione ridotta era la forma
che era inquietante
mi ha raccontato la forma era quella
propria di un ciuccio da bambini diciamo
che ha deciso di non andare mai di
ciucci per i bambini che hanno raccolto
in fila un bel tabella sopra paesano i
piccolini in fondo ecco dimensioni
uguali che forma ovale
ma il dio con quelli più giovani pdl che
cosa ha fatto
e lei ha subito cosa questi libri
mazzarri scusate chiudiamo qui
scusami silvia era in vacanza con degli
amici io tornando al mare prima per
cucinare il pranzo e faccio un bel
sughetto con un bel po di peperoncino
ovviamente spezzettato a mano ecco beh
la mia ragazza tono prima degli altri ci
appartiamo in camera beh io non mi ero
lavate le mani del peperoncino che dico
solo che ha passato un quarto d'ora sul
bidet e a sciacquarsi poverina chili con
carne pensano più alle patatas bravas
[Risate]
fucci mette in bocca non lamentarti
tanto mezzo apap ciao ciao steve eastin
gratis mani di sale a circa negli anni
fa quando ero ancora fidanzata con il
mio ormai ex giorno stiamo facendo come
sembra un certo punto lì mi dice guarda
che maghi mi chiedo ma non che è
successo e mi fa il confine da solo sono
statati vola dentro al bagno
dell'appartamento
un quarto d'ora a sentire lui dall'altra
parte della volta sull'eletto definire
la cosa da solo ma perché preferisco
fare da solo anzi si può andare in gioco
track pack è brutto comunque c'è il
fatto che tu inizi a ballare e poi ieri
messa in un angolo essere un angolo cioè
tutto quello che non ti insegno dirty
dancing
no è sbagliato la tua baby merita di più
le sceneggiate di incontri alla sera
dovevo togliermi cominciato uno scambio
di messaggi con questa persona la quale
però non riuscirà a darvi la conserva
cioè fatto ci saremmo visti serata
perché questi aveva delle cose come non
la sai sono al lavoro lo devo capire se
puoi passare
ricordati che sto lavorando alla fine
fin dall'inizio di casa vado e scopro
che in realtà lei faceva la badante
quindi invitato a casa sua con i vecchi
dentro quindi rapporto sessuale ma
neanche ha valso la pena si è dovuto
consumare incontrato silenzio belle
ragazze mie scuse
no non lo dire da sempre questa mia
amica silvia si diano ti amo libia
abitava con la nonna è diciamo allora
lei abitava col nome e abitava con la
nonna e quindi diciamo che quando il suo
ragazzo veniva a trovarla a volte
capitava che la nonna magari giorgilorio
e quindi nel mentre tu sentivi la donna
poveri ma nella stanza accanto che
magari postiva ho lanciato che sono là
dove in ha sofferto un po di fratture e
che milazzo fidanzata silvia
salta mona mamma di valentino è una
preview che scopo di mio fidanzato
dell'epoca minimi non macchina penso che
si sa che comunque lo spazio nelle
macchine specialmente dei sedili
posteriori andato allo stretto e devi
giocare un po di punto e si inquini noi
optiamo per quella posizioni ed è stare
con lei
il numero se si fece pervenendo del
tutto quindi dovi avevo davanti il suo
corpo volumi davanti la mia così la mia
vita siamo insomma stanno raggiungendo
tutti e due il clou della situation bbc
di scoraggiare
ecco come maggiori diventa mattina una
signora anche lei con ovunque
benché la nonna di silvia senza
automatica è stata quella avuta col mio
ex ragazzo mentre eravamo intenti a fare
rock tempo improvvisamente più madri in
camera mi vede chiaramente praticamente
urgenti per i figli umano però continua
imperterrito a prendere tua che doveva
prendere la scena una camera dopo pochi
secondi rientro nella camera col pad e
degli astanti che per farsi perdonare
amy mi dà un mega ferrero rocher
dicendomi appunto scuse che era colpa
sua insomma che
ho bussato come se non bastasse dopo
poco entrato gioiellino la divertita
come mai fossimo tutti che cosa fosse
successo a parti di famiglia il 20 ma
non correrà no grazie
non so se è stato peggio alla volta il
culo bellissimo ragazzo tra l'altro
klinger faccia tutto il tempo
oppure quando un altro sinisa davanti e
disse silvio canta no però 6 indiane un
progetto c'è questa che si becca tatò
celine dion kant brav
e wolverine x o [ __ ] celine dion è più
comune di quanto non pensi sempre silvia
proprio di sì diciamo che voleva che lei
canta meglio
andiamo avanti
no questa via si arrabbia perché i
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video io ringrazio silvia li
ringrazio vale per cui ringrazio vale
per essersi prestata insieme abbiamo
osservato nella difficoltà mamma mia
ragazzi ecco quindi se volete commentare
fatelo mettendogli una mano sulla
coscienza utilizzando tanta tanta tanta
fantasia credo che un sacco di artisti
ed i visionari e abbiano fatto dei begli
esempi ok se io invito inoltre a farmi
sapere qua sotto quali sono dei temi che
vi piacerebbe guardare all'interno di
questa rubrica e soprattutto vi do un
appuntamento alla prossima settimana con
un altro video ciao ciao
stamane la mazza ma ho comunque mi ha
mai detto che la chiamata se non le
mandi volto con una foto del tuo cane lo
sai
prego io